[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن اطلاق المخطط
العام لمطار الملك سلمان الدولي في الرياض
السعوديه تجمع
14 دوله في شبكه لامراض الاحياء المائيه
تعزيزا لصناعه الاستزراع المائي
الرابعه تركب افتتاح مدينه الطيبه
النموذجيه بولايه لوي في سلطنه عمان
تستوعب 30,000 سنه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
بعد عامين من التطوير بجير الدرعيه يعود
لاستقبال الزوار وجهه شتويه فاخره في
الرياض
يوم مثير البرازيل تواجه سويسرا بدون
نيمار واختبار صعب للبرتغال امام
الاوروجواي
حياكم الله اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان اطلاق المخطط العاملي مطار
الملك سلمان الدولي وسيسهم المطار الجديد
في دعم خطه المملكه لتكون مدينه الرياض
ضمن اكبر عشر اقتصادات مدن في العالم
وسيكونوا مطار الملك سلمان واحدا من اكبر
المطارات في العالم سيمتد على مساحه تقارب
57 كيلو مترا مربعا وسيشمل سته مدارس
طيران بالاضافه الى 12 كيلومترا مربعا من
المرافق وسيعمل المطار على رفع الطاقه
الاستيعابيه لتصل الى 120 مليون مسافر
بحلول عام 2030 ومن المتوقع ان يسيم
المشروع بحواليس 27 مليار ريال سنويا في
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي غير النفطي ضمن
رؤيه المملكه 2030
ينضم الينا هاتفيه وزير النقل السعودي
مهندس صالح الجاسر مع الوزير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياضه اولا كيف
تقراون الاهميه لهذا المطار اليوم بهكذا
حجم بهكذا رؤيه وبها كذا ارقام ايضا
النقل كبيره
لقطاعات النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
والطيران
في المملكه
بفضل الدعم الاستثنائي التي تحصل عليه
يحصل عليها هذا القطاع من سمو سيدي ولي
العهد
وهو خطوه متقدمه في تحويل المملكه الى
مركز اللوجست في عالمي وايضا يمثل خطوه
مهمه في همم خطط مدينه الرياض اللي تصبح
احد اكبر 10 اقتصادات همم في العالم
معالي الوزير ايضا كيف سيسهم هذا المطار
في دعم خطط السعوديه بقياده ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان في انيربطا هذا
المطار بين الشرق والغرب بان يجي على
السعوديه مركزا لوجستيا عالميا مهما
كان هو
في توفير البنيه التحتيه
الذي تطور صناعه الطيران
[موسيقى]
في المملكه مطار ضخم جدا يعني بطاقه تصل
الى 120 مليون مسافر في عام
و ينطلق بعدها لاستهداف الوصول الى 185
مليون مسافر همم
وثلاثه ونصف مليون طن من البضائع بحلول
عام
2050 همم سيمكن المملكه ان تتقدم جوهريا
في هذه الصناعات العامه
ويربط مدينه الرياض في بقيه دول العالم في
شكل ثالث
معين لانجاز هذا المشروع والانتهاء منه او
حتى مراحل هذا المشروع
طبعا كما ذكر في البيان الصادر عن صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه الذي همم يعني يقوم
بتنفيذ هذا المشروع ان ااه تبلغ الطاقه
الاستيعابيه همم
التشغيليه
باكثر من 120 مليون راكب في 2030
وحوالي
185 مليون راكب في 2050 هذا مشروع اطمخم
جدا
يعني يتطلب عده سنوات
في انجاز ما احد المشاريع ضخمه ايضا على
الوزير هي الاستراتيجيه التي اعلن عنها
الامير محمد بن سلمان في ما يخص همم
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل للخدمات
اللوجستيه اليوم هذا المطار كيف سيساهم في
رفض هذه الاستراتيجيه ما الذي سيضيفه
اليها ايضا
حوالي ضمن هذه
الاستراتيجيه
ممكن اساسي استراتيجيه للسياحه همم ممكن
اساسي لخطط مدينه الرياض لانه مو همم
الاستدامه ممكن لكافه القطاعات ال- همم
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه وجوده الحياه في
مدينه الرياض والمملكه عموما
اشكرك جزيل الشكر هاتفيا التحقق بنا وزير
النقل السعودي المهندس صالح الجاسر شكرا
جزيلا لك
في السعوديه دشنا وزير البيئه والمياه
والزراعه المهندس عبد الرحمن الفضلي شبكه
الشرق الاوسط لامراض الاحياء المائيه
اختارت الشبكه مختبر صحه وسلامه الاسماك
بجده ليكون مختبرا مرجعيا للدول الاعضاء
بالشبكه التي تضم البلدان المطله على
البحر الاحمر والخليج العربي وتشمل 14
دوله تعزيز صناعه الاستزراع المائيه
والوقايه من امراض الاحياء المائيه من
ابرز المستهدفات هذه الشبكه كما تهدف الى
مساعده الدول الاعضاء على تطوير واستدامه
قطاع الاستزراع المائي وتشجيع الدراسات
والبحوث حول ممارسات تربيه الاحياء
المائيه والامراض
المختبر سلامه الاسماك بجده ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد عبد
الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه ااا من الرياض
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا المركز او هذا المختبر
مختبر سلامه الاسباك لماذا ايضا تم اختيار
هذا المختبر في هذا المشروع المهم
اهلا وسهلا بك وبالساده المشاهدين طبعا
نحن هنا في هذا المختبر الذي يضم فرقا
مختصه تعمل على مدار الساعه نعرف ان همم
تدشين اليوم الذي همم يعني تم برعايه
وزاره البيئه همم يعتبر حدث مهم على الاقل
في ما يتعلق يعني هذا القطاع همم وما
يتعلق كذلك ب- اا يعني حتى شبكه الشرق
الاوسط لي امراض الاحياء المائيه في
المملكه همم نعلم كذلك بان همم الاعتماد
الدولي من خلال منظمه الصحه العالميه
تحديدا صح الحيوانيه همم التي يعني تمثلت
بحضور مسؤولين همم في هذا المختبر طبعا
يوجد اكثر من غرفه يعني المختبر ليس عباره
عن غرفه واحده بتبيعه الحال همم يعني هو
منشاه اكثر منه همم يعني مختبر واحد
وبالتالي هناك اكثر من غرف مختبريه يعمل
فيها سعوديون وسع على مدار الساعه
ليعني
العمل بشكل متواصل كما تعلم نايف همم يعني
نريد ان نتعرف اكثر على كل ما يجري همم
يعني همم نستضيف الدكتور علي الشيخ رئيس
التنفيذي للبرنامج الوطني لتطوير قطاع
الثروه الحيوانيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
دكتور ابتداء نريد ان نسال عن اهميه هذا
المختبر اهلا وسهلا باحبكم في هذا الحدث
اليوم طبعا انا سميتها الصباح في الورشه
يوم تاريخ اليوم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في قطاع الثوره السمكيه انه همم يتم
المختبر هذا كان مختبر مرجعي لامراض وصحه
الاسماك اللي الاقليم كامل المنطقه الشرق
الاوسط وهذه النقطه طبعا جاءت بجهود سنوات
تراكميه من العمل وهمم بناء القدرات وكذلك
الانظمه والتشريعات الموجوده في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وفي المختبرات خصوصا
المرحله القادمه باذن الله راح يكون عندنا
تعاون مع الدول وثقت في السعوديه همم
هذه الخبرات وكذلك بناء القدرات والانظمه
والشريعات مختبر هذا طبعا همم مختبر رئيسي
همم يعني همم تحليل همم الاسماك
والمكافحه الاوليه للامراض خصوصا تصاب في
كثير من الفيروسات والامراض والبكتيريا في
المختبر هنا بيكون فيه الكثير من
الاجراءات المبدايه والاستبقيه لهذه
لمكافحه هذه الامراض
المسببات المرضيه للكائنات الحيه والتي
تنعكس بطبيعتها على الانسان لاحقا فلذلك
هنا مرحله اتباقيه همم لمكافحه هذه
الامراض المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم
في هذا المجال المتقدمه في في بشكل واسع
همم الانظمه اللي تعمل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تستقي منها همم الدول الشقيقه
همم نفس البروتوكولات وتطبقها يوم التعاون
على على قدم النساء بين الدول الدكتور
يعني همم نقول ما هي الخطوه القاده ما بعد
ما اصبح هذا المختبر مختبر الاقليمي
اليوم عندنا المختبر هذا رايكم تعقد فيه
دورات بناء قدرات لكل الدول المشاركه في
هذه الشبكه راح يكون عندنا تشريعات
والانظمه الموجوده تعمم وتشارك مع الدول
راح يكون من عندنا ارسال مدربين من
المختبر هذا للدول الاخرى بنوعيه الانظمه
الاجهزه
التحاليل همم طريقه الاداء عمليات الفحص
لسباقيه واللاحقه هذه كلها طبعا في
المرحله القادمه ان شاء الله باذن الله هي
همم الوجه المضيء لهذا مختبر طيب فيما
يتعلق بالمساله همم الصحيه انتم يعني اكيد
انه عمل لكم مرتبطه بشكل رئيسي بالاسماك
وعموما كل ما يوجد من الحيوانات في البحار
كيف ممكن انتم تطورون هذه العمليه طب انا
اليوم نعمل همم في الوزاره على ثقافه
اسمها صحيحه الواحد الصحيح الواحد يتكلم
عن جميع المنتجات اللي في همم يستهلك همم
الانسان
ناحيه السؤال الحيوانات والاسماكه وكذلك
النباتات في الصحه هذه مشتركه في جميع
المراحل سواء في مراحل البدائيه التربويه
او في النهائيه الانتاجيه فلذلك هنعمل
اليوم على برنامج اسمه الصحه الواحده همم
اليوم وزاره الصحه لديها هذا بنفس
الكونسبت موجود فان شاء الله المرحله
القادمه راح يكون عندنا ديمومه قادمه
لعمليات المشتركه بين الانظمه والاجهزه في
جميع المختبرات بحول الله شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور على كل هذه التفاصيل يعني هذه
ابرز التفاصيل
ومتعليقات هذا المختبر الذي ابتداء من يوم
اصبح مختبر ان اقليميا ومرجعا هنا في
الشرق الاوسكار
سلامه الاسماك بجده علينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الواحد الحميد الرابعه مستمره وفي
ابعد قليل
بدا من اليوم موجه امطارا من متوسطه الى
غزيره في السعوديه غالبيه في المدن
الغربيه
حياكم الله من جديد بالتزامني مع يومها
الوطني بتشهدوا عمان افتتاح مدينه الطيب
النموذجيه السكنيه في ولايه لواء والتي
تبلغ مساحتها 12 مليون متر مربع متضمنه
مختلف الخدمات والمرافق العامه كما تشتمل
ايضا على 1300 وحده سكنيه مع قابليه
التوسع لتشمل اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وحده
سكنيه مستقبلا مدينه لواء
النموذجيه في عمان تسوعب نحو 30,000 نسمه
وتطبق معايير التخطيط العمراني المستدام
والحديث
من مسقط نظام الينا موفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
اعتذر اولا هي مدينه لواء
لكن خليني اسال عن هذا المشروع يا عبد
الرحمن كيف يبدو الى اين وصلت مراحل
الانجاز في اثره ايضا حتى على قطاع
الاسكان في عمان كيف رصدته
نعم نايف نحن في ولايه لواء بمحافظه شمال
الباطنه في سلطنه عمان في مشروع مدينه
الطيب النموذجيه هذا المشروع الذي
اتى بامر من السلطان الراحل قابوس بن سعيد
للاهالي الذين تضرروا من ميناء صحار كانوا
ساكنين بالقرب من امينه سحر ثم نقلهم الى
هذه المدينه النموذجيه وتعويظهم باراضي لا
تقل الارض عن مساحه 1000 متر الى جانب
ايضا مبلغ تقريبا
75,000 ريال عماني اي ما يعادل خمسه
750,000 ريال سعودي
لمساعدتهم في بناء هذه الاراضي زميلي وليد
ياخذ جوله نحن في احد همم المناطق في هذه
المدينه النموذجيه نشاهد بعض المنازل يتم
بناءها حاليا
وتقريبا على وشك الانتهاء وايضا هناك فلل
تم الانتهاء منها وسكنها الاهالي هذه
المدينه نايف
يعني متكامله من ناحيه البنيه التحتيه
هناك ثمان مدارس موجوده في هذا الحي وهذه
المدينه النموذجيه الى جانب مركز صحي
متكامل ونشاهد ايضا احد المساجد تقريبا 11
مسجدا بها مرافق خاصه مجالس عامه ومنزل
للامام وايضا مدارس تحفيظ القران الكريم
ايضا ما تم تشغيله حتى الان في هذه
المدينه نايف خمس مدارس
وتقريبا المركز الصحي همم يعمل لخدمه
المواطنين الى جانب ايضا سته مساجد همم
هذه المدينه همم تهدف الى الاستدامه
الاجتماعيه وايضا استخدامه البيئيه
والاقتصاديه والمكانيه هذه المدينه ليست
فقط سكنيه ايضا هناك مخططات تجاريه يعني
اذا ما تكلمنا نايف بالنسبه المئويه فهناك
29% من المشروع الاراضي السكنيه
و12% سيتم تخصيصها للمساحات الخضراء
والملاعب وايضا هناك 19% هي معابر الاوديه
لان نشهد وكما نعرف ان عمان عندما تهطل
الامطار بغزاره دائما ما يكون هناك بعض
الاشكاليات بالنسبه للفيضانات
والمشاكل التجمع المياه هناك ايضا حرص على
عدم تكرار مثل هذه المشاكل بالاجان
بالجانب ايضا 17% هي مساحات لمناطق
التطوير المستقبليه وهناك ايضا اثنين
بالمئه من المدينه اللي على الاراضي
السكنيه عذرا الاراضي الاستثماريه
والتجاريه نشاهد ايضا هذا هو المجلس العام
في كل مربع سكني نايف مجلس عام هذا المجلس
هو الاتراح والافراح بالنسبه للسكان سواء
المناسبات همم الزواجات او ايضا الاعياد
ايضا مراسم العزاء كلها تتم في هذا المجلس
العام الذي هو جزء من ثقافه اهالي السلطنه
وايضا همم حضورهم اجتماعي وبرامجهم
الاجتماعيه يعني مدينه حقيقه نايف متكامله
بشكل كبير وايضا الحكومه العمانيه خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه حرصت كثيرا على
تطوير الاسكان في السلطنه وتوفير الاسكان
والحياه همم الجيده وتطبيق جوده الحياه
بالنسبه
فقط على منطقه الباطنه او مدينه الطيب
النموذجيه الجديده بكل الارقام اللي
ذكرتها قبل قليل عن القطاع في السلطانه
كامله يعني كيف يمكن الحديث عنه او تقييمه
من خلال مشاهده
صحيح نايف يعني لا تخلو ولايه هنا في
سلطنه عمان او مدينه الا وتجد فيها مشروع
سكني متكامل وهناك ايضا حرص من وزاره
الاسكان سواء تسليم الوحدات الجاهزه
للمواطنين او ايضا اعطاء المواطنين
المساحه واختيار المبنى الذي يريدون ان
يبنونه وفقا الكود البنائي الخاص بسلطنه
عمان لكن هناك حرس كبير من الحكومه
العمانيه هنا
لتوفير السكن الملائم للمواطنين همم خاصه
المتزوجين ومن لديه عائله ولديه اطفال
على كل هذه المعلومات الارقام من مسقط
العربيه عبد الرحمن الحسيمه شكرا يا عبد
الرحمن
تنتهي غدا في السعوديه فتره استقبال
طلباتي تملك العقارات من قبل الامانه
العامه لجان ولي النظر في تملك العقارات
احكام ودعت الامانه المستفيدين المتقدمين
بطلبات تملك عبر منصه احكام الى سرعه
استكمال نواقص طلباتهم وفق الشروط
والمتطلبات اللازمه
موجه امطار جديده ستشهدها العديد من المدن
السعوديه بدا من اليوم وفقا لما اعلنه
مركز الارصاد وتشير التوقعات الى هطول
امطار في مستويات من متوسطه الى غزيره على
جده والمدينه المنوره واجزاء من منطقه مكه
بالاضافه الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
الارصاد السعوديه اضافت ايضا ان التاثيرات
الحاله المطريه ستشهد تيارات هابطه نشطه
السرعه
والتساقطا للبرد والتربه مثاره وتدنيا في
رؤيه الافقي
من جده ينضم الينا محلل المركز الوطني
للارصاد عقيل العقيل سيد عقيل مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ما هي هذه
الحاله التي ستشهدها بعض المدن السعوديه
اين ستتركز هذه الحاله المطريه
قناه العربيه من اداره توقعات الطقس
والمناخ المركز الوطني للارصاد بالفعل
اصدرنا تقريبا جوينا على الاحتمال تاثر
اجواء المملكه بامطار متوسطه الى غزيره مع
التوقع بجرائم السيول على كثير مناطق
المملكه هذا اليوم اصدرنا تنبيهه متقدمه
على بعض اجزاء منطقه تبوك وبعض منطقه تبوك
كذلك الحال منطقه المدينه المنوره
ومنطقه حائل ومنطقه القصيم بالاضافه الى
اصدرنا تنبيه متقدم على منطقه الجوف قبل
قليل التنبيه المتقدم
معناه يجب اخذ الحيطه والحذر ورفع جاهزيه
همم للجميع نتوقع ان شاء الله تعالى خلال
هذا اليوم وهذه الليله ان تتاثر منطقه
تبوك بما فيها السواحل بامطار متوسطه الى
غزيره لا يستبعد جريان السيول والسيول
المنقوله على منطقه تبوك خاصه السواحل
منها في محافظه الوجه وكل ما اتجهنا همم
باتجاه الجنوب حتى منطقه المدينه المنوره
سواحل منطقه المدينه المنوره من المتوقع
امطار متوسطه الى غزيره مع جريان السيول
لذلك الانتباه والاجزاء الشرقيه ما بين
محافظه حتى منطقه المدينه منوره في ينبع
النخل وما جاورها كل هذه المناطق متوقع
عليها امطار متوسطه الى غزيره مع جريان
السيول لذلك من الفتى الانتهاء وان شاء
الله تعالى في يوم الثلاثاء في ساعات
متاخره من الثلاثاء والصباح يوم الاربعاء
من المتوقع ان تتاثر سواحل منطقه مكه
المكرمه بهذه الحاله الجويه هطول متوسطه
الى غزير الامطار وكل ما اتجهنا جنبا حتى
محافظه جده والاجزاء الشرقيه من هذه
المناطق بالاضافه تتاثر منطقه همم حائل
ومنطقه
حائل ومنطقه الجوف وبعض اجزاء منطقه
الحدود الشماليه بهذه الحاله الجويه وتكون
الامطار متوسطه الى غزيره ولا اقصى
الاجزاء الغربيه من منطقه القصيب متوقع
كذلك الحال عليها امطار متوسطه الى غزيره
ممتاز طيب بالحديث ايضا عن همم كميه
الامطار سيد همم نحن تبعنا مثلا في
الاسبوع الماضي كميه امطار كبيره اللي
هطلت على جده وصلت الى 179 ملي متر انا ما
اعرف اعتقد لاول مره تسجل في جده هذه
الارقام هل هناك توقعات مثلا ذات الارقام
سواء في ده او في المدن اا الغربيه او حتى
الشماليه الغربيه كذلك التي ذكرتها من
المتوقع ان تهطل عليها بامطار خلال الفتره
القادمه
هو صحيح للتصحيح هي وصلت 180 ملي على
محافظه جده وهذا اعلى تسجيل في تاريخ
محافظه جده نعم 182 ملي طبعا غزاره
الامطار وهذه الامطار يجب علينا متابعه
الاحوال الجويه اليهيا الزملاء في قسم
الانذار المبكر يتابعوا الاحوال الجويه
وتكون السحب لحظيا عن طريق همم متابعه
الرادارات دوبلر للمركز الوطني للارصاد
بالاضافه الى صور الاقمار الصناعيه حينما
تتكون هذه السحب على سواحل البحر او في
داخل البحر يقوم المتنبي الجوي بمتابعتها
متابعه امنيه ولحظيه ويبدا بتصدير
التنبيهات ويحتاجت الحاله الجويه الى
تصدير تحذير فيصدر المتنبي الجوي تحذيرا
همم يتم ارسال هذا التحذير الى جميع
الجهات الحكوميه ممتازه
عن الاليه اليه التنسيق واليه الابلاغ
الجهات الحكوميه متى تتم كم تاخذ من الوقت
همم يعني لو احنا توقعنا انه الثلثاء مثلا
القادم طول الامطار في رابغ متى من مفترض
ان تبلغ الجهات المعنيه او الجهات
الموجوده في هذه المنطقه
طال عمرك حنا عن التبع عائليه في المركز
الوطني للارصاد وهذه الاليه متفق معها مع
جميع الدوائر الحكوميه في بدايه هذه
الحالات الجويه قبلها بثلاثه واربعه وخمسه
ايام يتم اصدار تقرير اولي ونظره اوليه
شموليه على معظم اجواء المملكه على حسب
الحاله الجويه يتم ارسال هذا التقرير
لجميع الجهات الحكوميه ولجميع وسائل
الاعلام وبعد ذلك يتم ارسال التنبيهات
كانت تحتاج تستدعي الحاله تنبيها متقدمه
يتم اصدار التنبيه المتقدم يتم ارساله عبر
النظام الالي انذار المبكر الى اكثر من
500 جهه حكوميه واهليه واجهات خاصه هذه
الحاله الجويه ايضا يتم متابعه همم
التنسيق مع الدفاع المدني عبر الخط الساخن
همم مع الدفاع المدني بمتابعه الحاله
الجويه اولا باول ونستعدت للتحذير يتم
ارسال التحذير يتم ارسال التحذير
اليالاحظيا الى جميع الجهات الحكوميه
اليالاحظيا وتتكلم ايضا عن التحرير
والتنبيه المتقدم يعني المصطلحات ممكن ان
انتم شوفوها سيد بعقيل بس بالنسبه لنا
يعني تبدوا احيانا متشابهه او يعني ممم
متشابكه في بعضها يعني فكيف نفهم الفرق
بينها اذا سمحت
احنا عندنا في المركز الوطني للارصاد
ثلاثه انواع من التنبيهات التنبيه العادي
باللون الاصفر وهذه موجوده بشرح واضح
ومفصل عبر الموقع وكبر وكذلك الحل عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التنبيه العادي
باللون الاصفر هذا جبر الحاله الجويه
بفتره همم كبيره على على تكون حاله جويه
اذا استدعى رفع التنبيه الى اللون
البرتقالي تنبيها متقدما يتم اصدار هذا
التنبيه المتقدم كل هذه الحالات الجويه
متواجده بالتفصيل اذا اصدرنا التنبيه
المتقدم معناها يجب على الجميع اخذ الحيطه
والحذر ورفع الجاهزين التحذير هو اعلى
مراحل التنبيه في المركز الوطني للارصاد
ويتم تبليغ جميع الجهات الحكوميه وجميع
الجهادات العلاقه برفع الجاهزيه القصوى
لوجود تحرير او خطر من حاله جويه همم
شديده همم على منطقه معينه في المملكه
الممتاز شكرا جزيلا لك جدا ضميرينا محل
المركز الوطني للارصاد عق- العقل شكرا لك
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بعد عامين من التطور بجيريا الدرعيه او من
التطوير جيري الدرعيه يعود لاستقبال
الزوار وجهه شتويه فاخره في الرياض
الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلنوا اطرق المخطط
العام لمطار الملك سلمان الدولي في الرياض
السعوديه تجمع 14 دوله في شبكه لامراض
الاحياء المائيه تعزيزا لصناعه الاستزراع
المائي
الرابعه
النموذجيه بولايه لواء في سلطنه عمان
تستوعب 30 الف سنه
بعد عامين من التطوير بجري الدرعيه يعود
لاستقبال الزوار وجهه شتويه فاخره في
الرياض
ويوم مدير في المونديال البرازيل تواجه
سويسرا دون نيمار واختبار صعب للبرتغالي
امام الارجواي
حياكم الله من جديد يعود مشروع مطل
البجيري لاستقبال زواره اليوم بعد بعد
توقف الدم لعامين من الاعمال التطويريه
ويمتازوا مطل البجيري باطلالته على مفترق
الطرق القديمه للثقافه والتجاره في حي
طريف المسجل في قائمه اليونسكو للتراث
العالمي ويحتضن المطر ايضا العديد من
المطاعم الحائزه على نجمه ميشلان والتي
سيتم افتتاحه فروع بعضها لاول مره خارج
بلدانها الاصلي
من الدرعيه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عن
صفيان هاني مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
النشره الرابعه من الرياض بعد عامين يعني
البجيري يعود مره اخرى الافتتاح اليوم كيف
تبدو الصوره ما الذي رصدته ايضا بعد
انتهاء الاعمال التطويريه وخلاص احنا يعني
على وشك الافتتاح اليوم
نحن نتحدث اليوم انه هيئه تطوير بوابه
الدرعيه خاصه في منتصف عام 2020 والتي
بدات في اعمال التنفيذ وحجم استثمارات
لدعيه كامله بمبلغ يفوق الاربعه مليار
دولار يعني نتحدث عن هذه المشاريع تطويليه
اليوم همم بوابه الدرعيه تبدا في جني ثمار
وايضا اول اصول هذه الاستثمارات من خلال
الافتتاح بطل الجيني وكذلك حي طريف الذي
سوف يبدا في استقبال في الزوار لهاتين
المنطقتين ساعه القادمه سوف تبدا او سوف
يبدا الافتتاح الرسمي بحضور قاده السياحه
من دول العالم وكذلك معالي وزير السياحه
السعودي احمد الخطيب عموما سوف يكون ضيفي
معي الاستاذ طلال ساره وهو رئيس
الاستراتيجيه في هيئه بوابه تطوير ادعيه
مرحبا بك استاذ طلال يعني توم اول اصول
الاستثمارات التي كنا نسمع عنها سوف تفتح
خلال الساعات القادمه حي طريف ومطر الجيري
يعني اليوم هي تطوير بابدعيه تحتفل بحدث
مهم جدا في رحلات التاريخيه يعني وفي
رحلاتها في تطوير مشروع بوابه الدرعيه
بكامل همم تفاصيل بكامل مراحله همم يعني
اليوم حدث مهم جدا همم زي ما ذكرت نحتفل
اليوم باطلاق وافتتاح بطل البجيري وهو حي
البجيري سابقا لكن اليوم بنسخه الجديده
بثوب جديد بالاضافه الى حياه الطريفيه همم
طيب طلال بينما ايضا الكاميرا العربيه
التي تتواجد وتلتقط هذه الصور الخاصه من
الكاميرا الاخرى سوف هذا السؤال يعني
يدفعني الى ان اقول ما هي الاستراتيجيه
التي سوف تقومون بها لجذب السياح من
الخارج ام ان اعتمادكم حاليا على السياح
وكذلك المواطنين والمقيمين في الداخل طبعا
بالفعل هناك استراتيجيه زي ما ذكر في
البدايه الاستراتيجيه محدده لسكان الدرعيه
او سكان الرياض وسكان المملكه ومن ثم
المواطنين والمقيمين في دول الخليج
وبالتالي همم الزوار من جميع انحاء العالم
همم اليوم بنشوف انه الافتتاح برده على
هامش الوفد قمه السفر والسياحه هذا اليوم
في دوله 22 لاول مره يقام في المملكه هذه
من احد الاستراتيجيات لانه اليوم عندنا
قائد من جميع انحاء العالم في قطاع السفر
والسياحه برعايه معالي وزير السياحه همم
الاستاذ احمد الخطيب وهو الامين العام
لمجلس اداره هيئه تطوير بوابه الدرعيه
فاليوم هذه احد اهم استراتيجيات انه قاده
السفر والسياحه يبدا يشوفوا الحيه البجيري
وهو اولى افتتاحات الموجوده في الدرعيه
وحي الطريقه التاريخي اا
اه في سؤال اخر السيد الرئيس تنفيذي لهيئه
بوابه تطوير الدرعيه سيد جرار يعني تحدث
في خبر صحفي سابقا سوف يكون في 20 30 27
مليار دولار من الناتج المحلي او الناتج
السياحه هنا في الدرعيه سوف يكون دخل
اضافي لميزانيه السعوديه هل هناك ايضا
استراتيجيه لوصول الى هذا الرقم وان ايضا
اكثر من 55 مليون ساعه سنويا سوف يكون هذا
هذا الرقم المحدد بنسبه الاستراتيجيات
ايوه طبعا بالنسبه لعدد السياح تقريبا من
55 مليون صحيح همم من داخل المملكه ومن
خارج المملكه وبخصوص الناتج المحلي صحيح
لانه مشروع هي تطويل بوابه الدرعيه هو
عباره عن مشروع متكامل همم حضر متكامل من
مكاتب من همم سكن من مدارس من اكاديميات
من جامعه من محلات الذئاب في الطبيعي وجود
هذه العناصر كامله مع بعض في المشروع تؤدي
الى زياده في الناتج المحلي وفي تركيز
ايضا على زياده في النادي النادي
هذا وزياده في الناتج المحلي ايضا شكرا لك
استاذ طلال لكن ساره وهو الرئيس
الاستراتيجيه هنا في هيئه تطوير بوابه
الدرعيه اذا بالارقام 55 مليون ساح سنويه
سوف تكون هي الوجه القادم والاستراتيجيه
القادمه لهيئه بوابه تطوير الدرعيه في مع
حلول 20 30 وكذلك الناتج المحلي بالنسبه
للسعوديه بمبلغ فوق 27 مليار ريال اذا
ننتظر نتائج هذه الاستراتيجيه مع ايضا
الصور الخاصه في الجهه الاخرى كما تشاهدون
الان بسرعه همم
كذلك شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لضيفك ايضا همم
الكريم على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من
الدرعيه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سنبقى في المونديال والتزامنا معه
والبطوله المقامه طبعا في قطر هيئه وزاره
الصحه السعوديه مستشفى ميدانيا في مدينه
سلوى يضم المستشفى طاقم الطبيه مكونه من
اطباء
وممارسين وتمريض من مختلف التخصصات
[موسيقى]
بالتسامح بطوله كاس العالم في قطر يقدمه
مستشفى سلوى الميداني خدماته الصحيه على
مدار الساعه للقادمين والمقاتلين عبر
المنفذ الحدودي الذي يربط السعوديه بقطر
المستشفى تم انشاءه في مدينه سلوى بمحادات
مستشفى سلوى ك جاهزيه لا سمح الله عندما
تزيد الطاقه او تزيد الحالات عن الطاقه
الاستيعابيه لمستشفى سلوى وكذلك في حال لا
سمح الله الكوارث والحاجه الى فرز الحالات
بعيدا عن المستشفى الرئيسي
مستشفى سلوى الميداني الذي انشاته وزاره
الصحه بمحاذاه المستشفى الاساسيه تبلغ
مساحته 600 متر مربع ويضم غرف التنويم
تتسع لنحو 50 سريرا وغرف عمليات وغرف
عنايه المركزه ومتوسطه كذلك يضم قسما
للطوارئ ومختبرا مصغرا وغرفه اشعه كما يظن
طاقم الممارسا ما بين اطباء واخصائيين
ويوجد نحو 200 من الكوادر البشريه من
ممارسين وتمريض في جميع التخصصات تم
استقطابهم كقوه عامله في الحدث كم استحدث
مهبطان للاسعاف الطائر بالقرب من المستشفى
اضافه الى مركز قياده وتحكم وصخر في
مستشفى السلوى وذلك لتنسيق بين جميع
القطاعات الصحيه
تم انشاء مركز القياده والتحكم مصغر في
مستشفى سلوى وذلك للتنسيق بين جميع
القطاعات بين التجمع المنطقه الشرقيه تجمع
الاحساء المديريات الشؤون الصحيه بالاحساء
والشرقيه وكذلك مع قطع الهلال الاحمر هنا
في مركز العمليات تتم استقبال جميع
الحالات العاجله وتصعيدها او لا سمح الله
الحاجه الى البلاغه الوطنيه للتعامل مع
جميع حالات الكوارث لا سمح الله
ما يقارب 750 حاله تم استقبالها منذ
انطلاق كاس العالم وذلك عن طريق قسم
الطوارئ وقسم الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه
والعيادات الخارجيه في مستشفى سلوى العام
من مدينه سلوا على اللغب العربيه
والى تقريبا جديد من قصص موسم الرياضه
ايضا معها زوار الموسم المزيد مع زميله
شهد المتروك
يا مرحبا يا مرحبا حياكم الله تفضلوا
نورتوا المكان تفضلوا ونورتوا قريه زمان
وعاداته وتقاليده في قريه زمان التي تعكس
ثقافه السعوديه باكلاتها الشعبيه وعروض
الزفاف ذات البهجه والالوان السعيده
قريه زمان تاخذنا لام مزنه التي تنتظر
زوارها المملوئه بادوات ما عادت مالوفه
عند جيل اليوم ومعلوم الرجال فهو مكانه
الاختبار الحقيقي لعادات وتقاليد الشعب
السعودي مثل صب القهوه
اسمك
ايه الحفلات الغنائيه ارتدت الطابعه
القديم بصوت الفنان عمر سليمان الذي اطرب
حضور قريه زمان بصوته الشعبي ضمن فعاليات
موسم الرياض
بره
بدول الغربيه بس المهرجان هذا مميز لانه
اول شيء دوله عربيه
واتكلم مع كل الناس مع كل الجمهور باللغه
العربيه
لذلك انا مرتاح جدا
وقدم تحياتي الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
على هذا المهرجان موسم الرياض
احبك احبك العربيه
[موسيقى]
على الاحساس بالتغيرات المناخيه خلال
السنه تفاصيل في تقويم عقد الزواج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ابتعاد الزواحف والقوارض عن بطون الاوديه
ومجاري شعاب دليل على قرب قدوم الوادي
ولجوء الطيور الى اوكارها بشكل مفاجئ دليل
على قرب عاصفه عنيفه
وفوضاويه حركه النمل ونقلها بيوضها الى
الخارج دليل على قرب حاله مطريه غزيره
وتوقف المياه عن الجريان في غصون الاشجار
دليل على شده البرد فاحساس الحشرات
والنباتات والزواحف والقوارض احساسها
بالمناخ وتقلباته احساس مرهف
اما يعتمدون عليها في معرفه الاجواء
المستقبليه كعتمادنا على الاجهزه الحديثه
فالكون كله خلق بتناغم عجيب يستدعي
الانتباه ان كل شيء خلقناه بقدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وصفرار وجه السماء واوراق الاشجار دليل
على اعتدال الاجواء بين قوسين الخريف
والعام يسمونه موسم اصفري ليش لانه موسم
الانتقالي ومن شان المواسم الانتقاليه ان
الاجواء تكون فيهم متقلبه فينتشر الغبار
على وجه السماء فتبدو مصفره وذوقه وجهه
السماء وزرقه الاجساد دليل على شده البرد
والعامه يسمونه بموسم الزيرك فخلاله تهب
علينا رياح شماليه تكسح الغبار والهباء
فتبدو السماء مزرقه ناصعه وحمره وجه سماء
وقرص الشمس دليل على اخر مواسم البرد برد
العجوز وبرد بياع الخبل عباته ذكر دردشه
مضى ظهرت الدنيا وجنات النعيم الى دخلنا
الشوط مره السماء
الحميد
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه
الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن اطلاق المخطط
العام لمطار الملك سلمان الدوليه في
الرياض
السعوديه تجمعوا اربعه عشره دوله في شبكه
لامراض الاحياء المائيه
الطيبه نموذجيه في سلطنه عمان
تستوعبه 30 الف سنه
بعد عامين من التطوير مجاري الدرعيه يعود
لاستقبال الزوار وجهه تنشر وتويتر فاخره
في الرياض
شكرا لكم على كرمل لطفي المتابعه دائما
العربيه دوت نت لمزيدي من الاخبار
والمعلومات نهايه الرابع اعود والقاكم يوم
غدا في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]